*fart*
Eh.. what a way to...
Hey, how's it going bros?
My name is PewDiePie
I can't yell
Ok?
I gotta be a little low key today
*sneezes* Fuuck
God damn it. Sneeze compilations, don't!
I don't have much time today, so im recording extremely early
Just so that i can, uh..
Have a video out today
*laughts*
"The whole world"
Hey, you wanna take a selfie?
Just for Coonstagram
Uhm... Ok I forgot what we were doing
Enter the genetics lab
Is that here?
No, it's far away
Okay. We must journey
Urh
Goddamnit why to i have to start it like this?
It's a terrible start, I'm sorry
ok
Alright
Yay
Uhm...
This could be..
Our last episode
I know
It's been quite a journey
Thank you for following with me
This far.
But we're gonna end it goddamn it, if it's the last thing I'll ever- ugh
I should not talk like that
Aw man.
I don't think anyone records this so early. All YouTubers are always up so late, aren't they?
Fucking hell, I'm doing it wrong.
Doing it wrong as a YouTuber
Where's the goddamn- uaghhh
I walked the wrong way.
Here we are.
Okay, oh no this is where the Happy Tree Friends kinda guys are, the satanist animals or whatever?
Remember that episode? *high voice* I remember!
*sigh*
That made me think of the first game
Er- The first game...
...was so good.
They improved some stuff for this one, but
We'll see.
Oh, I remember that episode!
Super old episode.
For real?
*laughs*
Now, we're gonna use the kite thing, aren't we?
What- it doesn't...
Oh, okay.
Uhh-
The genetic one. Uh, its one of the first season's episodes, I think
I had those episodes on VHS.
So good.
Ooooohhh
Ass, ass, *laughs*
Freeman, thank you. Quickly, quickly.
Yeah, I was already scanning it.
*chuckle*
On the left side.
Oh wow, of course!
How could I have been so blind?!
*laughs*
I'll fire it up!
Oh, okay.
Do I need to stand closer maybe?
We switch from daytime to nighttime?
That's our last ability?
Cool, we did it.
You guys alright here? *laughs*
Ooo this is creepy, I like it.
They did the Michael Jackson dance in the end of it too.
It's so cool.
Reliving my childhood, man.
*Ominous music*
*stops*
*chuckles*
Oh wow, okay.
That's how it started.
Oh my God.
Can I have another ass?
*laughs*
Yes, of course. The four hour- the four ass gorilla.
OH! haha
It's just like this, yeah.
They have butts!
They all have butts.
*laughs*
I think this guy's an ass man, I don't know.
Ugh
His cane has a butt on it.
I remember.
*laughs*
Oh my gad!
Ooh my good-
Oh my gosh, the cage breach!
That's a lot of ass.
Many assed cats, everyone.
Can't wait to fight the many assed cats. That's-
That's just what this game was missing.
I don't know, aw they're all gonna move in now.
Jesus